[Music]
saying no to things you don't want to do
is easier than saying no to things you
do want to do how do i navigate all the
things i'm interested in without having
a calendar that's bursting at the seams
wow i don't know that i agree with the
premise of this question
because i think quite often it's har
just as hard to say no
because you think you want to do the
thing so here's what i mean if someone
at work is asking you to come to some
christmas party and there's a and you
know you just don't i hate christmas
parties but there's an expectation
in that corporation to be there
it actually makes it harder
to say no to that because everyone
else is going to be there and societally
culturally and in terms of your peer
group
you feel like you're supposed to be
there yeah so it's really hard to say no
to other people's expectations it's
equally hard to say no to your own
expectation because ultimately
it is only your expectation you've
picked up their expectation and now it
has become your expectation so the the
second part of this question how do i
navigate all the things i'm interested
in without having a calendar that's
bursting at the seams it's by
the way that i do it is i don't obligate
myself to too many things there are so
many things i want to say yes to
that i'm excited to say yes to yeah
unfortunately we mistake excitement with
passion
now passion
is the result of
well it's actually the result of a
willingness to suffer
past us
is the root of passion which means to
suffer
so
whenever we are doing something that is
a little bit of drudgery you're writing
a book is a lot of drudgery right
but there's a lot of passion involved in
that it's sort of throughout that dip
the other side of that is where the real
passion happens the excitement happens
early on you get really excited about a
book idea or you get excited about a
party that you're invited to or some
event that you want to attend and so you
put it on the calendar three months from
now six months from now but then
a month away you look out here like oh
no and then it's oh no it's this
wednesday
i can't believe i said yes to that
so if i can look at my future self
because the thing i don't want to do
is i don't want to burden my future self
with unnecessary obligations
i would much rather say no
now when godzilla is a baby
then when godzilla arrives six months
from now and he's taking over because
it's harder to say no
the day of oh yeah don't you hate when
someone cancels on a podcast with us yes
i don't know what it is about los
angeles but not just the podcasting but
there's like this thing where i and i
find myself where i'm like oh i can't
make that today because of whatever
reason
but there's something about um the air
in l.a where everyone's constantly
making plans and breaking them the day
of and i'm guilty of it and i try not to
like for the first couple years i'm like
i'm not going to be that person i'm not
going to be that person and then
sometimes things come up where like you
just can't help it but the podcast
especially because yeah then we got to
scramble at the last minute
yeah it's like hey i wish you would have
said no four months ago right
instead of an email the morning of or
the night before yeah it's just the
worst now sometimes they're some things
are unavoidable right hey i got kovid
today right okay totally get it nothing
we can do about that yeah but other
times just like hey i had a conflict
yeah hey i thought this was remote no
you didn't yeah because we actually send
you all the details several times and
mallory and and sean have it highlighted
and bold and yellow and
it's like
the only thing we could do other than
this is like show up at your door and
say hey did you know it's in person
dude the conflict thing
is the worst because what they're saying
is is something more important has come
up yeah yes
yeah yeah especially when it's just a
conflict you're like oh they have a
better opportunity okay yeah like which
would be fine just say no up front and
so that's what we're really telling
megan here
is you don't want to be that person
because it does two things it stresses
out the other people in your life and
you don't want to do that but it also
stresses you out you don't want to have
to obligate yourself to something in the
future you just simply have to let go of
it's like picking up a bunch of clutter
what we're talking about here is picking
up calendar clutter
that's what this whole maximal episode
has been about calendar clutter we pick
up a lot of clutter just to let it go
in the future well the best way to
declutter is to not pick up the clutter
in the first place amen
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free